well no no I think I'm being told that
the the games have started ok well then
here we go I'm gonna pull up the games
right now we're still getting them on
camera and hold on just a chick we will
have it soon chat so let's see I mean
it's full see going to be able to
survive out of the opening against
voyboy such a heavy favorite here yep ah
here we go I've I'm suddenly nervous boy
boy getting the first move look at that
quickness boom she says ok she's going
for the caro-kann I mean that is that is
really impressive she needed to prepare
with the black pieces I think she you
actually helped her with this but but
look how fast she played there yeah I
mean 0.4 seconds is she has more time
than she started with this is a great
sign knowing she would just went full
look at that she's pre moving oh my gosh
foosley
I respect I respect the hustle she's
trying to scare voyboy I love it boy boy
is wearing the beanie again it just
makes his brain look bigger it's an
intimidating technique the Coneheads was
the thing at some point not not a very
cool thing but ok moving on firstly I
feel I feel like this is a message she's
trying to send let's let's take a listen
to see what she's talking about
absolutely yeah I'm gonna faced do it
I'll take your Bishop you know I will
I'm not phased okay so we have an
impostor hat going on we are probably
gonna build out this hat part oh no no
not yet not you I almost done blocked my
bishop what are you doing oh my god
Bishop where do I put this thing this
pins his his guide to the kind like that
we are we are pinning your knight voyboy
how do you like I love that I'm too
confident okay this is my next move
we're getting the Hat development I'm
not nothing boom boom okay sure that's
alright lights which is all good I
like by letting anticipating I mean if
you go here if you but I'm always a
little bit worried players make it out
of the opening and then what's gonna
happen right but so far so good
boy boy also has that pin on the c6 but
that's a lot less intimidating she can
always take backward pawn versus a
knight on f3 there's some risk you'll
have to mess up his full-on structure on
the Kings side wow that was yeah I mean
like you said some I was just impressed
by how quickly she's played because also
the position is is you know totally
equal right I mean very close to Daddy
quality as everyone can see not just
from the eval bar but players developing
their pieces 97 was a little risky
Alexandre cuz it blocks the bishop which
in turn blocks the castles so that might
be a move she'll wish she had back you
could have just developed the bishop
then gotten the knight out and gotten
castled so she'll have to move her Jeep
on and develop the bishop or bring her
Knight to f5 if her plan was to bring
the Knight to f5 then this makes quite a
bit of sense yeah but I think we'll see
how we'll see how boy-boy handles it I
I'm getting a sense that this is one of
the moves you you said the risk of
playing too fast is will you make a
blunder right she was playing very
confidently in fact up about a minute on
the clock over boy-boy but this is this
could come back to haunt her that she
caused that kind of dysfunction to her
ability to get the King out of the
center right and let now that she put
her Bishop on f5 she's not gonna be able
to put her a knight there so her
development is about to get a little bit
awkward but yeah on that know maybe we
should to listen in on what voyboy is
saying about this as well to do it
nice music cave
so I go contrary to popular belief
listening to classical music not make
you smarter go something like that or
help your chest but at least it doesn't
distract forget about that it's gonna
take your two moves to get this picture
out three most the castle he's
highlighting it
I could go Queen here one move there's
after she's doing this Bishop here two
moves Cakes takes I got nothing I need
to get this Knight as another attacker
but now that the bishop is unpinned I
might be able to bring this over see my
wife with me saying okay so she moved
your bishop again two kind of ways to
move gonna see a six to try and push the
bishop away it's a bit of a
counterintuitive move because you're
pushing a pawn on the side before you do
that yeah well no now if she plays a
sixth what you were talking about that
would actually help but he seems to have
a pretty he seemed to have a pretty good
idea of what the problems were in blacks
position listening in on him like he was
describing like it's gonna take her
three moves to get the bishop out and
that's gonna cause problems here so I
think that he wait how is her diamond
pink and mine is blue what the hell it's
just there well he doesn't know he can
change his Flair that's hilarious he's
complaining about her diamond
I guess Leslie to have to give them the
tip so that he can make it a little bit
more customized I think he wants the
pink one too judging from his outfit
no g6 made so this feels a little bit
concerning because she didn't do
anything about the pin but also her dark
squares are gonna be a little bit weaker
now if he sees him it was like Bishop g5
to create double pins it's gonna be
tough for her yeah g6 is risky but it's
sort of a symptom of the problem she she
started when she put the knight in front
of the bishop for that national diagonal
so there's also pretty sure that if
boy-boy sees it he could play f3 and
maybe even trap this bishop
the middle of the board here I mean this
is a good call
but maybe f3 and g4 also just moving
Bishop g5 is a huge problem because you
threatened to take the dark squares and
now you're threatening to take here cuz
the knight is pinned to the Queen so boy
boy I think rightfully pausing a little
bit here
to make sure he finds the right approach
and as a coach what would you be more
proud of moves like f3 or Bishop g5 here
Bishop g5 for sure to not create
weaknesses well I think that Bishop g5
is a more like wow and he finds that and
I'm kid genius for a reason right Bishop
g5 but takes Advaita like Bishop g5
shows your critical thinking that you
recognize the problems with g6
immediately right it's like I think it's
a coach it's like you want to see things
like that where someone plays this move
and they don't miss the chance to
immediately expose the weakness and
something that's changed because a lot
of people make up their mind in advance
what their plan is and they don't adjust
when things are changing coming at them
but he he immediately finds the best
move and I think this is uh big trouble
here for
and you can see loose Lee's reaction she
seemed quite animated so I think she
senses that she's in trouble here and
now if she just continues with business
as usual Bishop g2 to try to continue
castling all of a sudden he can take the
knight on c6 oh she does sense it okay
so she defends the knight one more time
that's a very good move on her end as
well it shows great positional not
positional but tactical understanding
that she might be double agreed
it's sacrificing the dark squares of
course you know Bishop f6 could be
played but but it might have been the
right poison to swallow as they say she
was sort of picking between them all
right
now it's his turn to continue here it's
getting a little bit trickier so she
hasn't been able to Castley it yep and
now if she does the f7 pawn hangs to so
I'm I'm sorry I'm kind of watching them
and just trying to read on their body
language I mean again we highlighted it
and not to kind of you know pick apart
the point but I really believe right
back here everything was going well and
you can even see the computer start to
give white just a little bit of an edge
on 97 didn't like this move and for good
reason it caused this function that
starts to get revealed later on so um
let's go let's go full screen with
foosley again and see what she's talking
about with those highlights that's what
I'm going to do even though this is
defending this and this these guys have
back up here this guy has back up here
so wait oh my god okay that's fine
that's fine that was issued freaking me
out cuz it waiting that um I love hurry
I could don't think mm like maybe I go
like this is it better time with my
queen here my bishop here my bishop is
protecting nothing my queen is really I
think it's trying to move my bishop up
it develops it I can still castle it was
a huge I'm gonna castle next moon and
she found the right continuation yeah
and now she's sitting has she been
thinking on his turn as well when did we
lose these pictures it's not a very good
job whatever we're listening you don't
know if I suddenly feel like my child
yeah I'm not to talk over he doesn't
notice but like what it's gonna be like
this than this right and as soon as I
can do that
so watch he's gonna know okay so that's
our new problem that was a little too
scary kind of worth like what do we do
this right we go here he takes he
doesn't even see the nice
I love with your calculated on line that
starts with our called D right okay she
cancelled though she figured it out that
that is awesome she's made this I mean
okay so it started here when voyboy
played Bishop takes e7 and this is I
said I was proud of this move as a coach
Alexandra then this move is like you've
never trade a more active piece for a
less active piece especially when the
position is just begging for you to own
the dark square so this was a huge
mistake the computer didn't like it
either
and now Foose Lee is right back in this
game absolutely and andreas playing
music really loud in the background can
you guys hear it at all or is it alright
little simply as you know okay yeah it's
like that's my mom I don't you've heard
like there's like vacuuming going on in
the background here no one can hear it
either okay okay but I'm gonna ask her
to turn it down I love I love being at
home during Cova it's really been great
yeah really been great learn with your
little sister no inconveniences at all
yeah fantastic and us okay right okay
wow this this is actually crazy because
even though even though f3 like doesn't
work it's because of something that
firstly would have to see that's very
tricky to see if the bishop just
continues to go backward white will trap
the bishop but the only way to save it
at some point might be because of this
crazy tactic Bishop c2 where you bring
the Queen to a square and take advantage
of a pin on the C Pole and this is like
super gross yeah that's gonna be
impossible to see exactly which is why
fousey just made a huge mistake so this
was one of those really tricky positions
where even though even though we were
right that boy boy miss played it
firstly had to see some really tricky
ideas to save it and one of them was
maybe this crazy pin you bring
Queen to a square and the point
everybody is if the pawn takes it Lucy
would win the Queen for free and this
this winner this would actually maybe
won the game for firstly but that's a
super hard move to see this movie it was
even deeper cuz then let's not go deeper
into the line it is a hard one to see so
instead she went for Queen a5 you're
trying to threaten a piece but
unfortunately he can trade off first
get rid of the threat and then take the
bishop on e4 yeah the other thing she
could have done was you know traded on
e5 perhaps and and we saved it but I
think void boys reasoning now
Alexander's making more sense to me it
was still a mistake by him but the
reasoning he played Bishop takes a 7 is
I think he spied this Bishop trap idea
and just kind of committed to it he was
like oh I'm just gonna go trap the
bishop but it but it doesn't work if
Foose Lee actually finds the right ideas
to either trade or play Bishop c2 so
none of can forgive him for giving up
that dark square bishop but he did get a
little bit lucky right well now he's
going to be up a full piece he's a
little bit lower on the clock do you
think fousey loosely still has any
recovery chances I mean she's only down
a piece but the problem is she's down a
piece too one of the better players who
seems pretty confident let's take a
listen in on him cuz he is stretching
and let's see what he has to say
cracking her armor nice when the piece
pawn takes I can take back with Knight
she brings rook here I could also go
there I mean pretty nice for Khan the
two rooks
it might be kind of logical she could
also bring the other rook over but I
have some nice like things on her King -
so she's got to be pretty careful I
think what I like is that he thinks on
her time this is a really important in
rapid games
here come the five heads Chad are you
proud of him GoPro wait you weren't
asking me you asking sure no that's
that's important to you
whoo we did like a little louder it's
getting even more intense I love it and
this is non copyrighted right oh god I
hope so
Oh DMCA's for me please
I actually have a fantastic update on
DMCA oh gosh
such a thing I got a strike because I
was listening to 50 cent in the club
right but yesterday I found a remix to
in the Chess Club by an artist who
doesn't have it copyrighted so guess
who's gonna be playing that on stream
next that's right uh first of all if no
one has heard into Chess Club will
someone please share that link with chat
it is one of the we did a contest on
chess comm more than five years ago
which is where that incredible video
came from no don't give spoilers wait
for us to show it on on stream at some
point it's too good ok I'll let you
reveal later but did you know that that
came that that video was the one that
won our contest we said make a viral
chess video and that video won yeah I
thought chess calm in the YouTube
comments like this is fantastic so I
assume that was related to it yeah many
years ago back when we were like this
internet thing is here to stay I hear
they're talking about a viral video
let's get the kids to make one and they
did kids of Erbil yeah alright well for
boys doing well now he's coordinating
his pieces coming toward the Kings side
um this is one of the more instructive
ones I think for Foose Leah you know
it's one of those ones where as a coach
I would say regardless of the tactics
later that could have saved her
Alexandra the the energy you put the
energy you put into analyzing this game
should really just focus on probably 97
early that we were talking about there
was no reason to create those problems
for yourself oh she just hung the f7
poem
don't a lot of a lot of puns are hanging
here and then he's gonna have some scary
checkmate tactics with stacking on g6 oh
that would be actually a beautiful
finish for a void boy yeah let's see it
see it the reason I say that is because
even if there's tactics later that could
have saved a game if they're the kind of
tactics that it took an engine to make
you realize we're there then they
probably weren't on your your critical
thinking process and you should put your
energy to focusing on things you can
control which is like alright if I get
this structure again these are the
mistakes I made that I can really put to
memory and really commit you right like
I can't rely on some crazy tactics to
avoid boy
despite his mistake of Bishop take c7 I
think has been pretty much in control of
this game since you know really since
this move here on MU 7 or she willingly
kind of blocked her own development
there so yeah exactly and again this is
what I was talking about earlier I think
the players who have been putting in the
work they're able to get out of the
opening alive but then the tactics start
coming on and it's just impossible to
prepare for situations you don't expect
and that's where the more experienced
player is gonna take the W as the boy
boy is doing here yeah it would take a
big blunder but let's go listening to
Foose Lee some more she's doing a great
job and let's see what we see what she's
got to say right like
what like this isn't really defending
anything except this piece she he could
take this but I could take this I'm
gonna just do this wait what was that
the move wait I can't move his piece
what was I gonna do
what oh my god what was he gonna do what
was my move for no doing this because I
can't
Oh like this I feel like he's ten steps
ahead of me I'm playing extremely
reactively I can't beat him her chad is
going nuts what if I go like this I
don't know where he feels I love
actually right now he's not that scary
do you know exactly what's happened here
I can defend against it I think I just
go over here I'm I start attacking him
well oh my god she seems happy
so that's that counts for something
regardless of what's going on on the
board she seems pretty psyched about you
know like she's living with it yet yeah
it's tough and she knows she's like as
she said she's like I feel like he's ten
steps ahead of me and I'm just reacting
which is how it feels
any Jefferey just players had that where
you just feel like you're constantly
reacting and and that's where she's at
right now so yeah and she's definitely
intimidated talking about how he's must
be ten steps ahead
but that's Wow he's finding the tactic
Danny I mean he's what Chuck made her in
two or three depending on what she plays
here that she played fantastic that was
the forcing made and of course there
were a number of ways to win here Chad I
mean you know you could have taken with
the night you could have just brought
more pieces in but boy boy finds the
most accurate way to win which just
speaks to his experience I'll just show
the checkmate that's coming if H takes
Queen takes you have a choice between
King H a and get mated by the knight or
King f8 and get made it by the Queen so
rook takes g6 is
that's uh that's pretty good stuff there
from boy boy no he has been working on
that tactical I I mean this was just
quite a mismatch obviously the the games
are gonna start getting a lot closer as
we have the two halves of the group
breaking off into the champions division
and a contender division yeah but until
there she's gonna have to practice
against number one in the tournament yep
and we were talking with the earlier not
to change the Senate this game still has
more but okay what I just predicted is
about to happen a checkmate in two and
we'll see which one foolishly chooses
but I believe the void Boyd will have to
meet some of his challengers really in
the in the second half I think he's
gonna win this his quad right the quad
that's happening now and then
here we go wow that was that was just
clean what can you say right you guys
you gotta tip your hat and or take off
your beanie if your void boy no yeah
that's my cue Danny I think I would have
to try it for the next competitive game
I do on stream
Haga games the game classy
[Music]
and we are live now with mr. Beeney
himself I want to call you the legendary
beanie you left the camera boy boy and
went and got that beanie and then
started the best game was what was the
reason for that yeah so I my chest our
client the Phantom beanie I started
wearing this to originally keep my hair
out of my head cuz I'd get a haircut in
months it's long overdue and so I got
this pink beanie because I love pink and
it kind of makes me look like Patrick
Starr a little bit so I could channel
some of his genius and it turned out
when I was on a big chest losing streak
recently I put on my phantom beanie and
I just I went like six games in a row I
just started smurfing and I just got my
confidence back so now I just have to
wear for anything that requires me to
like you know be performing at a peak
level I think it it like it optimally
constricts the blood flow around my
brain and like it pushes it into like a
into like my medulla oblongata and then
it allows me to like a stand and like
like do everything better like play
league better play chess better like I
don't know I think there's something
going on there I mean a lot of chess
players are actually superstitious and
they'll wear the same shirt if they won
in it and like if they need to wear it
seven days in a row they will but you
just took this - oh my god well they're
there Vic you're not washing it as often
as I would like to say but I want to
give you a chance to tell us how you
felt about this game so you first of all
congratulations you're - no but this
game started out this game Sarah I mean
she was she was bringing the tempo she
was bringing the confidence so what was
going on there with how are you feeling
yeah she was playing really well I mean
her first move it's not something that I
like had experience with I my chat told
me after that hikaru helps her prep it
you know I was pretty impressed because
she was like pre moving like going ham
like she knew exactly I was she actually
knew exactly I was gonna do and yeah I
was really impressed like she was moving
faster than me she wasn't really making
mistakes I tried like a few different
tactics that I thought were good ideas
and I was like oh I thought this had her
like a pretty good chance of working at
different points at every single time
she just like she just like stopped in
its tracks I was like god damn let's
just think so well like I don't like
where am I gonna get this it like
advantage that I needed and I finally
found it but it took it took like you
know most of the game to get there so
yeah I was like really close game it's
funny because we just saw a preview of
her on the game report and I have to say
that we spent most our time highlighting
that her first big mistake was right
here when she didn't play Bishop d6 she
should have developed and yeah and not
locked her own development with the move
Knight to e7 which is what she didn't
and we listened in on you and you did a
good job kind of describing the problem
with this that it was gonna take her
several moves to get castle so was this
the first moment you had a little bit of
confidence yeah that's when I realized
that I could try to set up some sort of
like initiative on on that night that I
had pin cuz like I realized for my games
and just like like watching and learning
a lot more chests like lady like pins
like early especially or so opie like
that's why that's why I like people try
so hard to break them with like the
random like h3 right basically you would
stuff like that yeah exactly like it
because it just creates like such a
vulnerability so I was like okay so I
saw this pin it's gonna take her like
extra long to castle so maybe I can try
to pressure it and I knew that that
Bishop on g4 was like the reason I
couldn't like get my knight for more
reinforcements on g6 so I was like okay
let me try to like see if she'll trade
it off if she does I'll take my queen
and I have like more pieces on the board
I'm already cast like I felt pretty good
about this position if it happened and
then um she ended up not trading it and
moving it back but I think yeah where
she moved this so this was where I was
like okay now I have some like some
options but before this I was like man I
don't really know like how I'm gonna try
to get a lead yet and then when she did
I was like okay now I have a free move
my knight I can go for something and
then I was surprised like she didn't
really let me get like a lead in the way
I thought she would but yeah I was it
was pretty it was pretty little spicy
she brings it's nothing more than you
you you finished your plan of oops sorry
I jumped ahead there but you played 95
and then you started playing great I was
actually really applauding the move
Bishop g5 I was highlighting as a coach
Alexandra asked me because you had two
ideas after g6 one was to immediately
try to trap the bishop yeah three yeah
but you guys I didn't pocket that's it
what did you hear me talking about that
or you just knew no I just Oh
just something we were we were talking
about um but but I actually think this
is the better move you you recognize the
chance to take advantage of g6 with this
but but then I'm only gonna say this cuz
I've watched you your streams now I know
you appreciate a little bit of criticism
you use our game report to all the time
yeah this has an uncommon analysis tool
yeah I've seen you using it and by the
way I really like your suggestion to
turn the target into a like a pink thing
instead of a great thing that's Jesse
the guy in whoops should be you should
get they should pat you on the back for
getting a good move not like yelling you
like oh it's gray like what in life that
is like good is great right like thank
you it's depressing if you get a good
move it should be at least like at least
a color that inspires a little bit of
hope not too much like the light like
the lime-green it's like nice you made a
perfect move but just like yeah like
like a pink like a pink that would be
personal we flip this moment right now
and send it because we are gonna turn
the target into the color of void boys
hat I'm not kidding wait like before
this I was just like I'm gonna spend the
next ten years of my life trying to
improve and become a GM so that way I
could make like I could contribute and
move like the void Gambhir like the
frozen mallet
yeah like the chess industry but then
now I just in like two days like now we
got we now we're gonna change the good
move to a pink like dude I'm done that
now I can just quit chess I I changed
the game like that's all I had good well
I wanted to talk also about something
that happened on stream yesterday so a
big rivalry box box said that you took
challenger away from him in league and
the only reason hopefully this event is
to try to take you down
you got any rebuttal for him uh yeah so
I did I just see that so what happened
was box box was playing his master promo
not he's not quite challenger but he's
he's on his way I'm not either right now
you know leaves a struggle sometimes but
anyway so I I beat him I hard carried
against him in the game he needs to win
for his master promo as a good friend
you would think Oh like I would go easy
on him like maybe you know give a chance
no no he needs to
that and just like he needs to earn this
chest pogchamp championship he wants to
meet me in the next round or whatever
like you know albers Aang bring it on
but I destroyed him the master promo and
I'm gonna fudging destroy him in the
chess match I hope you spent 50 hours
studying my openings and analyzing my
games and get coached by Hikaru
Alexander danny and magnus carlsen
cuz no matter what you do box box I will
destroy you you're gonna be one box
smashed into a little cube and I'm gonna
checkmate that I'm team boi boi now I'll
work with you I don't know if I can ever
be on box boxes team anymore coaches and
then he's doomed that's genius
well boy boy in that case I'm gonna have
to stay loyal I'll have to support box
box but respect respect for that trash
talk no stay even after the beanie what
if I brought you the pink beanie you
know loyalty is high and you already the
favorite I honestly respect I respect
that no problem as you got you got me
though and we're gonna change that
target so we're gonna let you go man
again great game you played played well
and it was awesome when we tuned it and
saw your thought process I'll let you
get back at it we're gonna get set for
the next match but that look for the
target color to be updated at some point
here hey let's go alright thank you guys
so much thank you so much
and good
you
we lost him we lost boy boy but they can
still hear us
oh wait can you hear me now oh we can
hear you now yeah I just try to say oh
sorry I don't know if I was taking up at
the time but I started a really good
game to Leslie I thought she played
awesome I'm really excited to see how
she does in the next match and yeah
thinks everybody bye awesome and see ya
alright that was awesome good good
sportsmanship they're coming back into
two wishes Vesta Leslie and give her
good luck
that's our schedule coming up for those
of you who are maybe tuning in again to
this event for the first time the date
is June 9th right wait no today's the
8th close enough Danny okay so hey did
my best
like do I need or Leslie you're here yes
I'm here hi hey thanks for being here
I'm Danny with just I think you already
know Alexandra yes nice to meet you
Danny and nice to meet you too so you
you had it first of all you had a great
story out the gate here you were playing
quickly playing confidently where did
you where did you feel that you maybe
first played too quickly or what what
went wrong from your point of view and
in this game yeah so my strategy was to
play so quickly that he didn't realize
that I moved at all so that he would run
the clock down and I actually thought
that that would work but it didn't so
then so then I just was playing okay I
was trying to make the Hat a bit and I
remember that the big thing here is like
developing so I realized that I need to
develop in order to castle so I made
this move Knight to e7 I believe and
then that's when I realized I messed up
because I I made my first mess up
because I blocked my bishop and after
that my brain just like spiral the Mo's
like know I messed up it that I don't
and then I blended it again and
blundered blundered and that I just went
downhill from there well if you realized
you messed up then you had the right
strategy so you think this was because
you were playing too quickly in the
opening yeah I wanted to play quickly so
he would think that I was confident so
that it wouldn't like mess with him so
he'd be like whoa she's kind of good
like maybe I need to rethink my moves a
little bit
we were - we just caught up with him and
he and he kind of said that he kind of
knew you came really well-prepared and
then I saw you were we saw you streaming
a minute ago analyzing that you're I
don't even need to say anything cuz
y'all ready talk Bishop d6 would have
been great and then and then the move
you played would have been awesome right
to support the knight defend everything
and get counseled it was really just
that putting the knight in front of the
bishop first caused all kinds of
problems oh my goodness yeah I'm mad
about that and I was looking at the
analysis and it just blew my mind that
like like there's just moves I can't I
couldn't see like I didn't even dare to
move my knight up or wasn't my bishop or
something it was your bishop later on
I'll show ya you you had a great game
and then we got to this spot here where
he was trapping your Bishop right and
you could have moved it up here or
something like that
yeah you want to tactic Danny yeah yeah
I can can't see it or I mean I'm looking
at the screen now honestly yeah you
shouldn't really beat yourself up but
you had this crazy idea where you could
have played the bishop here to bring the
Queen and then take the pawn here which
would have been horribly hard to see it
actually works because the pawn is
pinned and and if he takes it you win
his Queen for free oh my god yeah I see
it
we lose anywhere you get to kind of pick
up the knight here you could also win
the bishop so it's okay but this is not
the kind of thing you should beat
yourself up about at all because that's
a very very difficult thing to see I
think if I was playing the coach hat
which I'm not your coach so sorry for
you know suggest but I would say but the
main thing to focus on in this game
would be would just be the beginning
just just not creating the problems for
yourself because as before that I mean
you were up a minute on time you were
playing great I think that was really
the main thing to adjust in the future
yeah and I have I wasn't expecting to
win this one because it's voy voy but
you know my match against Nate will be
will be the deciding factor to see who
goes into the winner's bracket or losers
bracket so I'm gonna prepare let's talk
about and you had a fantastic first game
you had them checkmate in 13 and now
you're gonna be playing Nate who is a
much similar rating level to you so
what's your strategy for that match I
can't say you're right I'm sorry I'm
sorry I didn't mean to bait you like
that now I actually don't have one yet
but I'll work on one I will have a
couple days right it's on Friday yeah I
have like four days I'll think of
something
but you know maybe I'll do this maybe
I'll just execute it better maybe I'll
learn a different defense but that match
I'm looking for it too a lot along along
with everybody I think as you said
that'll be the match that decides who's
who's going on most most likely so
honestly watching watching your stream
you're the improvement is real this has
been you know crazy to see so it's
awesome awesome to see that you're gonna
get get back at it on Friday and good
luck thank you yeah yesterday I lost to
a 545 like random and it blew my
confidence like I I was I yeah it was
not the best game to play before this
one but I'm gonna keep practicing you
know I've had a lot of fun learning and
yeah even if I lose on Friday and then
lose again in the loser's bracket I'm
still happy because I did get one win
and that's better than I expected to do
this whole thing definitely money robbed
though awesome attitude and don't worry
that 500 was probably stream sniping
yeah yeah true yeah there's a lot of
there's a lot of that going around these
days so all right Leslie well good luck
on Friday and hopefully we'll catch up
with you then alright thank you so much
right goodbye
and there was Foose Lee Leslie who's
pretty awesome and she legit has
improved a lot I mean you're you called
it Alexandre that she might be someone
for an upset the way she started that
game I was impressed and then and then
like you said made a little too fast
right but you could tell that she even
knew the mistakes she made so it does
show that she's been learning and
putting in a lot of thought into the
games so impressive to survive that long
nevertheless